déjà l'effet enfin le premier effet tu
m'a paru bizarre par rapport à ma
première injection c'était vraiment un
goût métallique dans la bouche un goût
de métal dans la bouche grosse fièvre
exactement il n'est pas normal oui tout
à fait et essoufflement important c'est
ça nous on va c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois parce que jean-paul ce goût de
métal dans la bouche c'est normal ça ou
pas
bon ça a été décrit c'est pas comme
comme comme des effets comme les gens
qui n'ont plus de goût les gens qui
n'ont plus d'odeur
quand on a essoufflé on pense plutôt à
un début de mieux car dès qu'un risque
myocarde est qui et qui arrive rarement
mais qui existe
alors à partir de combien de temps vous
les avez ressenti tout de suite après
oui tout de suite après c'est à dire
quoi oui il m'a immédiatement dans les
jours qui suivaient dans les jours qui
suivent vous êtes dit c'est sûr que ces
vaccins c'est ça voilà on me l'a pas dit
médiatement c'est ce que je déplore un
petit peu je suis en train de pointer du
doigt pharmacovigilance puisque j'ai été
donc entendue par monsieur ville annick
et président du comité parlementaire des
choix scientifiques et des choix
scientifiques et technologiques qui
justement 130 tabler sur la question de
la
fin de du recensement entre les mains de
pharmacovigilance puisqu'aujourd'hui un
médecin un urgentiste quand si vous
diagnostic une pathologie grave ou pas
d'ailleurs il n'a pas l'automatisme de
de poser une question sur oui ou non
vous avez été vaccinés et si c'est le
cas est ce qu'il ya un lien c'est pas le
premier automatique bras pour un médecin
et donc on peut mettre en cause à
l'heure où on parle les chiffres qui
sont entre les mains de
pharmacovigilance en tout cas c'est une
question que les rapporteurs se pose au
sénat aujourd'hui alors il doit à la fin
de l'été vous est atteinte d'une
infection bactérienne du rhin c'est ça
qui est l'eau des frites oui
pyélonéphrite et du gauche que vous
traitez avec des antibiotiques et vous
retourner travailler en septembre vous
finissez par faire un malaise à votre
travail entre deux audiences et le
médecin vous détecte également un
problème cardiaque là vous prenez
forcément ça là avec balade à la
rigolade oui sur le moment j'étais le
choquait j'étais étonné je me suis dit
que c'était ma fatigue générale qui crée
cette arythmie et au départ je voulais
pas le croire non bah oui fin à 31 ans
vous dit votre coeur à les défaillants
vous avez une arythmie fin musique royer
pas trop sur le monde est là le
cauchemar continue oui on vous et louise
puisque dans les semaines qui suivent
vous développez des douleurs très
intense dans les jambes comme des
brûlures internes exactement ça
jean-paul aussi c'est ça arrive parce
que là j'ai l'impression que la pauvre
et louise
alors sur la myocardite s'étaient connus
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que on a
arrêté de faire des vaccins
le vexin de modern art on a arrêté de le
faire chez les gens qui avaient moins de
50 ans parce qu'on avait découvert que
dans des cas qui étaient quand même
relativement rare il y avait il y avait
132 cas sur un million de vaccins de de
mieux car dit il faut savoir quand même
que la myocardite la plupart du temps
c'est c'est sans séquelles il ya des
milieux cardiff d'origine virale et moi
j'ai vu un membre de ma famille jeunes
qui a fait mieux car dit il ya quelques
années qui a été hospitalisé quelques
jours et qui a repris complètement une
activité normale avec le sport donc
c'est vrai que mes la myocardite c'était
connu c'était un des effets du vaccin
132 cas sur un million juste et le
windsor et une fois les chiffres ils
sont à revoir avec pharmacovigilance et
eloïse on va on va continuer parce que
ya pas que ça héloïse j'ai une petite
question posée vous avez donc 31 ans 32
32 aujourd'hui vous étiez est ce que
vous aviez des problèmes de sons du tout
aucun antécédent moi là je pose la
question est la vraie question qu'on a
posé plusieurs fois dans cette émission
héloïse 31 ans
elle n'a pas de problèmes de santé
pourquoi at-elle fait le vaccin je suis
désolé même s'il ya il faut calculer le
bénéfice risque jeu désolé elle n'avait
pas à le faire je suis désolée elle
aurait elle j'aurais préféré qu'elle
attrape le coc vide voilà à 31 ans elle
est en pleine santé elle aurait été
béral aurait bien moins de problèmes que
celle ci fonctionne à passer le bac ça
maintient mais voilà la fée vaccin là
pour moi c'est vraiment je vous dis ça
c'est ce que j'ai dit maintes et maintes
fois ici il faut que raymond à chaque
fois calculer le bénéfice riz sur une
personne de tournon en bonne santé je
suis désolé le vaccin n'était pas
indispensable et elle n'aurait pas dû le
faire je suis désolé jean paul rey peut
excuser moi non j'ai pas tort
[Applaudissements]
vous avez tort parce que malheureusement
le rapport bénéfice risque il est en
faveur du vaccin oui nous
jeunes
gens possible avec monsieur villani le 4
avril il est en train de parler
justement de la défaillance de
pharmacovigilance g et médecin
jean paul chapalain gabon tout juste à
vélo y donnait fruits légumes et bah on
va recenser chez toi il faut savoir que
le 12 juillet du 12 juillet jusqu au 8
mars et j'ai pas été recensés non mais
je suis pas je suis peut-être un cas
d'école et eloïse et louise moi je
voulais pas me dire que ça à l'instant t
bonds et louis sans voix quand on chante
on est jean paul hamon c'est pas de sa
faute mais je suis enchanté mais quand
j'entends des médecins vous dire c'est
regrettable mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en
fout dans ton petit regrettable sa vie
elle a des problèmes de santé alors
qu'elle en avait pas avant sa vie elle a
basculé alors qu'elle était tranquille
elle a rien demandé à personne on va
elle va faire le vaccin comme tout le
monde à ce qu'on m'a dit il faut faire
le vaccin sinon tu vas rester chez toi
tu vas pouvoir rien faire tu vas rester
en dehors de la société est aujourd'hui
eh bien il aussi ce qu'est ce qui se
passe à la 32e eh ben il a d'une
multitude de problèmes de santé c'est
pour moi je vous dis c'est inadmissible
je suis désolé c'est inadmissible et et
le bénéfice net sur une personne de 30
ans je vous dire ce qu'il faut calculer
c'est le nombre de personnes de moins 2
comptant ou de 30 ans qui ont vraiment
des problèmes et je peux vous dire que
moi pour à mon avis le qui ont vraiment
des problèmes s'ils avaient eu comme
idée sans être taxés je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup moins qu'ils ont des problèmes
que ceux qui sont fait vacciner jeudi et
là c'est ça qu'il faut calculer mais ça
pour moi sa conjointe le cas des lots et
des lobbies je suis galerie parce que
c'est vraiment votre cas me touche je
suis chanson je suis désolé je chanterai
cc c'est ça qui s'était on peut passer
au tout le monde l'a dit de la
vaccination c'est pour les plus âgés je
suis désolé pour les personnes à risque
elles étaient parisse elle a pris elle
même un risque de ruine mais elle était
obligée de le faire parce que sinon elle
aurait peut-être perdu son emploi elle
aurait pu sortir de chez elle elle
aurait pu prendre les transports en
commun et on a le on a une maj moi je
suis hyper scène je fume pas ne boit pas
et où jamais problèmes de santé depuis
ça mais règle alors j'ai été réglée à 30
ans est absolument n'importe quoi c'est
de la même manière je
transmets n'aurait de neuf mois
aujourd'hui j'ai plus de règles c'est
voilà c'est incroyable les tremblements
aussi on n'en parle pas moi maintenant
je tremble et les pertes de mémoire
aussi j'en ai depuis ça alors qu'avant
j'avais ma mémoire
donc il ya beaucoup de personnes que je
ressens sur mon comité qui ont des
problèmes de mémoire c'est incroyable
aux logiques basculèrent je suis pas un
cas d'école alors là péricardite pour un
ami le chirurgien que je salue à
l'antenne d'ailleurs donc nizar voilà
péricardite aiguë et louise vous avez
donc trente deux ans vous avez fait
vaccin 31 ans 2e dose de vaccin et jette
victimes d'effets secondaires on va
rappeler les effets secondaires d'abord
vous avez des douleurs très intense dans
les jambes comme des brûlures internes
au départ apprend vous décèle une
incontinence des veines profondes des
deux jambes aussi ça vous avez oublié et
vous fait perdre en urgence oui ça c'est
l'évêque tami c'est pourquoi aussi hein
ça c'est assez courant aussi
et ils vous avez des problèmes
cardiaques vous avez eu une infection
bactérienne du rien du rhin
aujourd'hui elodie est ce que hello his
vous vous auriez fait quoi si vous
auriez pu venir à en revenir en arrière
bah déjà j'aurais pas un site est ma
mère assa vacciner parce qu'aujourd'hui
votre miraculeux 63 ans mais peut-être
que c'est vrai que oui mais votre maman
je pense que ça va oui mais enfin
j'étais pas d'accord avec bien
évidemment j'étais d'accord avec mes
deux soeurs il ya derrière par an pas
très bien non donc on
est là elle a eu une fatigue générale et
mais vous l'avez aussi si vous avez
envie d'un donc voilà est là qu une
fatigue générale ça va c'est normal que
je culpabilise et que je pense à ma mère
au vu des effets que moi je subis enfin
des effets votre maman je pense qu'elle
a bien fait de faire le vaccin moi je
suis pour les personnes voilà oui
j'avais je suis quand même p si vous
voulez c'est également face à deux demi
soeurs qui était voilà pas pour le
vaccin dont il y avait un débat
familiale et moi j'étais pour gt vous
étiez pour le maquillage et même
chanceuse il n'y a pas de débat il n'y a
pas de malade pour le vaccin voilà vous
avez oui mais voilà après après après
moi je suis comme le dit on l'a dit si
je suis contente de ne pas avoir vacciné
machine est en tout cas d'accord la
trêve à gaza l'âge 7 ans d'accord non
oui ça ton fils et c'est ça va oui jean
paul vous dire quelque chose de vital
non il faut pas refaire le débat sur le
show sur le vaccin à si on a compté
simplement incontestablement le vaccin
il a il a permis d'éviter d'état
d'hospitalisation il a permis d'éviter
des tas de mort et c'est vrai que si le
vaccin a des airs bénéfices on a des
effets sur les concierges c'est une
faible partie une très faible partie de
la population les chiffres on est sur
des chiffres mais bien sûr sur le coup
le par exemple les que je prends
l'exemple quand il s'est agi de vacciner
les adolescents s'est agi de vacciner
les adolescents on s'est aperçu on s'est
aperçu qu'il fallait systématiquement
faire un test pour savoir s'il a vu le
cog hill ou pas parce que si on faisait
une deuxième dose chez des adolescents
il y avait un risque de myocardite blanc
à cas sur cent quarante mille d'accord
et est donc moyennant quoi on a fait ce
test là
à tomber mais quand vous avez quand vous
êtes sur une population que vous
vacciner l'ensemble de la population
si vous protéger les personnes les
personnes fragiles regardez ce qui se
passe actuellement où les gamins dans
les classes retire les masses qu'ils en
avaient marre on comprend bien mais
qu'est ce qu'on voit nous en ce moment
on voit des classes entières où il ya
neuf gars dit qu'à 15 cas ces gamins là
il rentre y voient leurs grands parents
y voilà
la troisième dose au mois deux mois de
septembre ces gens là fragile
pour moi elle alors et j'avais dû faire
le vaccin il ya de nombreux médecins qui
s'attaque aux rémois de l'eau professeur
ah oui il en meurt raul tentant l'ace de
will et
il n'y a pas que
mon ami gilbert des dations voilà j'ai
une question pour vous weezer a signé
son contrat avec l'état français où il
ya une clause qui dit pfizer ne sera pas
responsable donc la répression soit rue
mêlée mais laissez moi finir en cas
d'effets secondaires ce qui d'ailleurs
perturbera l'indemnisation éventuelle
d'eloïse ma question elle est simple
est-ce que pfizer ne savait pas un
moment qui aurait des effets secondaires
et aurait caché il vous savez c'est sûr
et certain les états ont imposé un
rythme accéléré peau de mise sur le
vaccin de mise sur le marché du vaccin
qui a été mis sur le marché en moins
d'un an avec des procédures qui ont
toutes été respectées mais dans parce
que ils ont ils ont gagné du temps sur
sur les sur les évaluations sur les
phases est incontestablement files
heures savait qu'il avait vacciné des
milliards de personnes et qu' il pouvait
pas se retrouver vous savez il ya des
actions de justice les actions de classe
vous avez des groupes ce qui s'est passé
pour médiator je peux vous dire que la
médiateur c'est un pur scandale mais on
pouvait pas exclure qu'ils aient y ait
des effets add on savait qu'ils auraient
des effets sommaire
mais les gens sont mais les gens sont
protégés par l'état jean mi mandat s'est
engagé fin j'aurais raté dédouaner mais
l'état s'est engagé jean paul quand vous
dit tout à l'heure il ya des enfants
dans les classes a pris moi l'enfant par
an qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout qu'ils
s'arrêtent pas là transmission on peut
transmettre aux mêmes conséquences dans
leurs crampons mais leur action ils sont
vaccinés donc ils sont mais juste à côté
et on s'est dit on attendait
quand elle la troisième dose au mois de
septembre que tu commences on sait très
bien que l'immunité n est pas l est pas
éternel notamment chez les personnes
âgées qui ont une immunité qui est
défaillant que donc effectivement tu
fait courir un risque à des personnes
fragiles
moi je trouve ça très bien qu'on donne
la parole à quelqu'un comme hello his
parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des médias ne
veulent pas relayer ce genre de
témoignage pourquoi parce que la moindre
personne qui remet en question
l'efficacité du vaccin ou qui en
dénoncent les effets secondaires est
taxé de complotiste aboutissent de quoi
parce que là on a vu qu'il ya des gens
qui ont des hommes qu'elles étaient trop
vagues simple là on a bouclé les gens
qui ont des intérêts clair à faire
l'apologie du vaccin quel est l'intérêt
d'eloïse aujourd'hui de dire je suis
victimes d'effets secondaires graves
aucun donc il faut laisser la parole à
ces gens-là et arrêter de voir les
arrières et lorsqu'on est ce qu'elle
reproche c'est pas c'est pas le vaccin
c'est le fait que la pharmacovigilance
soit défaillante que justement
surtout qu'elles vont
alors qu'elle était en pleine santé un
an savez-vous ce qu'elle reproche en
vrai je réponds à moi j'ai vraiment
mal conduite de ce côté bayonnais on va
d'ailleurs commencer vous rayonnez on va
voir s'il est aussi bon je laisse la
parole à rimont on atteint 800 ici je
pense qu'il connaît mieux le dossier
vous moi je pense qu'on aurait vraiment
dû faire puisqu'on dit comprend toujours
exemple sur les autres pays à d'autres
bic ont fait fort c'est la vaccination
des personnes âgées je pense qu'on aura
dû forcer la vaccination des personnes
âgées et laisser tranquille derrière le
récent de 10 ans 12 ans 16 ans et pour
leur acidité présente et l'épousé mais
pour les personnes à risque ce qu'on
nous dit on a vacciné un môme de 16 ans
parce qu'on n'a pas été capable de
vacciner quelque 87 ans mais c'était là
le problème fallait vacciner à personne
2 87 90 ans au lieu de taper sur le
monde de 16 ans mais la personne de 87
ans va lui dire si tu ne vaccinent pas
tu pourras pas l'eau face ou d'hommes
genre à l'afutt chez moi donc c'est plus
de 16 ans mais c'est ce qui s'est passé
vous rigolez clés à chaque fois que mon
exemple de piscines et spas et c'est ce
qui s'est passé des effets secondaires
vous sortirez pondère de l'aco vide
aussi chez les gamins ils sont
rarissimes et il existe et si votre
gamin se retrouve en réanimation sans
avoir été vacciné je peux vous dire
combien
la culpabilité que pendant la première
fois que manny je suis un petit peu
d'accord avec toi non ma fille tu l'as
dit bah tu me l'a dit oui j'ai les noms
j'ai dis qu'effectivement ces gones ont
souffert des conditions non mais c'est
plus compliqué que ça ça que sur les
personnes jeunes au chili voilà sur les
personnes jeunes à france la question ce
qui est très compliqué c'est de faire du
cas par cas on veut savoir ce qu'ils
disaient c'était faut que chaque
personne à voir un médecin tu as besoin
t'as pas besoin ça on me l'a pas dit ça
au bien dit il a dit qu'il était voilà
pour les personnes plus âgées donc à
risque voilà bien sûr quand je vois avec
un soit 20 de moins ça ça me touche
c'est parce qu'elle a dit aussi delphine
j'ignorais donc effectivement que je ne
suis pas 100 % on n'est jamais 100% dans
un cas maintenant et je pense que le
rôle de l'état où le rôle des médecins
âme on essaie de faire un choix et c'est
de faire le choix de la majorité et je
reste quand même persuadé que le choix
de la majorité pour un mauvais cas comme
cette jeune fille et je le regrette
c'est très triste dans la grande
majorité je pense était positif bien sûr
maintenant je suis pas médecin
les mirabelliers que la barbarie comme
on l'appelle sur tous les réseaux là en
ce moment alors moi je vous ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention et d'émotions
effectivement voilà c'est ça affreux la
seule chose c'est que en fait le jeu
c'est pas un docteur on en parlait tout
à l'heure pendant la pub effectivement
c'est c'est affreux mais quand on
vaccine des milliards de personnes il ya
forcément plus de malchance qui est des
effets sur l'aide de dire ça fait d'être
ici à ouidah faire quand on a la
meilleure car d'année vous avez lu dix
neuf vies d'al wihda excuse moi c'est la
faute à pas de chance rien n'apparaît je
dirais ça il n'y a pas de terrain mais
ont duré ses mails avec eux et je
connais un vaccin on t'oblige à faire
plaisir et la
remercie
tu connais un bac 50 oblige à faire
sinon tu restes chez toi là-bas je crois
parce que la vaccination cyril vous
savez qu'il ya aussi des femmes qui ont
des problèmes d'aménorrhée
indépendamment de la vaccination ça
existait nocar dit un des papas ce que
je veux dire c'est que on peut avoir des
problèmes de santé la vaccination ici là
avant moi l'essentiel à 30 ans et la
fois d'avoir été vacciné la pallice que
vous êtes ça n'a pas l'air si la non
mais elle elle était en bonne santé un
an après se retrouve avec mon problème
de
relation de cause à effet n'a pas de
relation avec le coach en cependant du
temps
je dis que c'est justement
extraordinaire parce que grâce à vous
grâce à tout ce qui va remonter en grâce
à mon comité qui va recenser basse et de
pouvoir tourner aujourd'hui avoir une
ferme asile ans d'être à monaco
vigilance par certains médecins qui ne
veulent pas émettre une éventualité
entre le vaccin et les pathologies
qu'ils subissent à l'heure actuelle mon
client télé la chance à nos jeunes que
moi j'ai des centaines de témoignages
que
j'ai 50 mais lui et je n'ai pas ouvert
les messages depuis tout à l'heure parce
que ça s'enchaînaient et mon téléphone
voilà il me chauffe les cinq minutes il
ya des gens qui déplore le manque de
reconnaissance alors c'est pas aux
médecins de reconnaître leur lien de
causalité on ne demande pas un médecin
on ne ment pas monsieur armand ce soir
de reconnaître au lien de causalité pour
vous on est là pour dire si oui ou non
il y à une éventualité exactement à
partir de ce moment là le rôle et
l'obligation c'est même pas le rôle
c'est une obligation pour le médecin
c'est de le relancer mais le problème
c'est que ces de l'administration c'est
long et le problème c'est l'automatisme
à la tête du médecin à faire le lien
donc du coup il n'y a pas de recensement
et donc on a des statistiques qui sont
bénéfiques général dj je pense que vous
mettrez en pratique
jeudi
[Applaudissements]
courage ou non on
va pas bâillonner gilles j'ai aucune
agressé j'ai démissionné jeudi vous vous
dites à eloïse tant mieux grâce à vous
ça va remonter mais savait pas comment
elle galère il ya un autre avocat
d'ailleurs voilà qui se bat contre tout
le monde et de chair franchement cet
avocat il se bat vous me dites l'état
reconnaîtra l'état on connaît rien il
galère ils ne seront sans doute jamais
indemnisées jamais indemnisées donc
quand vous dites les données vont
remonter on va les collecter il ya une
obstruction majeur
si tout va bien par exemple la tension
mais vrai qu il ya un procès tant il ya
quand même y'a l'oniam qui effectivement
est limité dans ses responsabilités mais
l'office national des concerts
dernièrement
il ya eu l'idée une commission de
conciliation des effets secondaires il
suffit de déclarer à l'oniam
la démonisation qui est normalement les
gens c'est ce fait qui se fait à
l'amiable et c'est l'état qu'il
garantisse et kiki et ses détails et de
garanties tout ça y est je suis si vous
faites connaître quelqu'un quelques
accords passés quelqu'un qui vous a pas
fait autant
excusez moi aussi merci l'état
excusez moi mais il faut dire que l'état
remplacé son intention initiale de
l'oniam l'oniam c'est un organisme qui
étiez là pour indemniser les gens qui
estiment qu'ils ont eu des effets
secondaires pour une prise de tel ou tel
médicament de la vaccination donc ces
pré vinci il ya une commission il ya une
commission radier si cette commission
mais aussi sur commissions je termine et
si cette commission estime que si le
patient estime que la commission n'a pas
répondu à ses attentes il peut recourir
au tribunal
l'administratif joie
[Musique]
qualité avec la jeune yvonne juste les
chéris je sais que depuis la casse elle
est quasi vide aujourd'hui mon avocat
qui justement se bat pour toutes ces
causes il a un gamin de 13 ans
aujourd'hui qui a subi une thrombose
cornet qui lui a fait perdre 90 % de sa
vue donc le gamin est aveugle
aujourd'hui il faut parler faut parler
simple au palais clair l'oniam
aujourd'hui c'est 15 millions des impôts
des français on soit clair le gamin il a
été expertisé et au vu de ses préjudices
ces 8 millions on sait tout cela rien
addition non pas moi 15 millions -8
millions vous savez cette les centaines
peut-être des milliers de victimes sur
l'algérie c'est trop dur mais ça
permettrait si je peux me permettre
quand même là il ya un moment il ya un
moment où des pathologies pourraient
susciter des pathologies s'ils existent
c'est dans la population moi j'ai deux
cas dans ma patientèle à brad jeune
fille de 17 ans qui n'était pas baptisé
caffè une thrombose homicide
apprécieront cérébrale et emerson
labèque de ces maquis la vaccination se
42 ans ya fait une double embolie
pulmonaire n'avait jamais réussi à les
porter sur le débat existe